former president Donald Trump is back
here in New York City for the first time
since his historic arrest and
arraignment just last week Trump is
giving a deposition in a separate case
this is a lawsuit filed by the New York
State Attorney General focused on his
business dealings Chief Washington
correspondent Major Garrett is tracking
the former president's legal challenges
you are very busy major you have a lot
to keep track of these days but when you
put when you take a look at this one How
concerned should he be about this one
compared to the others look this week is
not last week last week was criminal
this is civil
and former president Trump throughout
his business career has done a lot of
depositions we had news Chopper coverage
last week because it was historic if
there were news Chopper coverage of
every time that Donald Trump had done a
deposition there'd be no news Choppers
left on the Eastern Seaboard okay yeah
that's happened quite a bit this is a
case brought by the New York attorney
general not just against the former
president but against all his children
in the Trump organization alleging that
it misstated financial documents as part
of a scheme to get tax benefits and
preferential loans Trump denies all
those charges
he had a deposition in August claimed
his Fifth Amendment right to abortion
400 times which is his right yes but in
a civil case if this goes to trial it's
scheduled for trial October jurors can
take what is called an adverse inference
from not answering questions they can
lean into that a bit more than you can
in a criminal case so one of many cases
pending so politically with all these
cases yes pending uh the former
president is fundraising off of it he's
selling T-shirts with a fake mug shot on
it so is he emboldened by this or is he
weakened by this politically look the
politics around the events of last week
are obvious for a moment there was a
rallying of the Republican party there
was fundraising but there's already
polling data that should suggest it's
not wearing well and will not wear well
this is a separate thing this is about
the Trump organization and on his own
social media platform the former
president said I'm eager to prove what a
great company that nothing was done
wrong and this is a ridiculous case that
I can win so in this case he is
asserting that he feels much more
confident about it and in the beginning
he feels confident in all of his cases
though yes but some of that is Bluff and
some of that isn't on this one they feel
generally speaking better grounded in
the law and what they did and the Trump
organization the company itself and in
the politics of it most people who
support Trump like his business
practices even if they're a little on
the edgy side Major Garrett always great
to have you at the team thanks thank you
appreciate